foreign
back to St Louis and talk to
Christina what's up Christina
Hi how are you partying what about you
I'm doing okay hey this is so far it's
been a show where I really don't have a
great answer for anybody so you may be
number three let's hope that I can do
better what's up all right well
um a few years ago my sister was
diagnosed with an aggressive form of
Parkinson's disease oh man what a mess I
hate that yeah now she's in her early
50s and she walks with a walker and
can't stand up without assistance yeah
and recently she asked me to help her
with some personal things like bathing
and things to kind of take some of the
pressure off of her husband
and um she told me that
she didn't think that she had much
longer
and because all of her efforts towards
treatments have had little effect in
slowing the disease
and I just need to know how I can best
help her through this disease knowing
that it'll eventually take her life yeah
and yeah I don't want to think about her
dying yet she faces it all the time and
her husband can't talk about it he
breaks down
and so she needs me and I need to know
how best to help her
just what you just called it out
um
somebody has to sit with her
who can
call reality reality and live out of
that
not just numb out and pretend
everything's gonna go on just the way
things are forever
I'm I'm I'm
heartbroken for the whole family I mean
it's just geez but there needs to be a
I wish I had another word for this there
needs to be a Reckoning with her husband
needs to be an ability for you here's
because here's the deal on the other
side of truth-telling
on the other side of true telling can I
tell you like my one of my oldest best
friends on the planet who's a paraplegic
on the other side of we just call a
spade a spade
we laugh a lot
and we're sad a lot but we laugh a lot
and we figure out how to get that guy in
his chair and get him to our restaurant
we've gone to concerts to go into the
Guns and Roses reunion show went to the
poison show I mean we go to show I mean
figure it out but that can only happen
on the other side of
now we're calling a spade a spade
everything's different yeah
yeah right and so I I if I'm you
um I would ask her permission to go out
for coffee or something like that a
place where she felt comfortable
and just say
I'm feeling a need to
just talk openly in reality wise and I
want to make sure that's okay with you
because at some point y'all gonna have
to talk about what you want her funeral
to look like
and what does she want
um does she have a will
and does she have a DNR or does she have
all of those things those can be holy
and people can think I'm crazy they can
be hilarious conversations
and heartbreaking conversations all
rolled into one
but they're coming from a place of
choosing reality and owning it and
moving forward in that way
yeah yeah you know what I mean
yeah
because here's the deal she knows
she does she knows she's an RN she's
been a nurse for 25 years she knows
and if you asked her
how much do you want to talk about this
I would love to talk to you about end
end times
what you want the next two months six
months five years of your life to look
like and by the way it is not uncommon
for people facing a terminal diagnostic
to say things like I don't think I'm
long for this world and what they're
trying to do is speak into existence I
want this to stop now
yeah I can see that in her okay she's
getting tired because everything
I heard right now that's right she's
getting exhausted she doesn't she's
watching her husband fall apart she's
watching her sister well up with tears
like she's a caring person she's an RN
she doesn't want people to hurt around
her she's tired of hurting she's
exhausted and so it's almost this
prophetic I want this to stop so I'm
gonna start saying it out loud that does
not mean it's gonna stop
okay it could be a long long time but I
think having the conversation about
skilled nursing and
when like give her some options into do
you ever want to go to a home or when
you when me and husband can't take care
of the care anymore what do you want
that to look like can y'all afford that
what is that like somebody's got to have
those conversations and she's in a spot
now where it's getting harder and harder
but she can still have those
conversations just needs somebody to
um adult up and do it
yeah
and my promise is entering into that
storm
will be so uncomfortable and when she
passes you it will it will give you
oxygen to know
how intimate and vulnerable and
connected y'all were in the last two
months or ten years of her life
yeah
um
it's I she's always been there for me
I was like chronically ill as a child
and all of the stuff I went through is
what inspired her to be a nurse and I
want to be there for her have you told
her that exact thing right there
yeah
okay
we're pretty close to
almost everything but not quite
everything
yeah exactly exactly
no but
um our son's getting married in a couple
of months and she recently asked me to
be like a mother to him during his
wedding and the reception everything
because she can't move around and do the
things that she wants to do
beautiful let her inform that
okay so when she said that she had a
very clear picture in her head take her
out to coffee
and
ask her tell me exactly what you want me
to do I'm I'm going to be there for you
we're doing okay
um and while we're here we gotta talk
will
and we gotta talk your knuckleheaded
crybaby husband he's got to talk and you
know y'all you just gotta go there
yeah and at some point you might have to
sit down with brother-in-law and say I
need you to grow up and we have to have
some hard conversations you can't just
fold out all the time on this
and I say grow up in an I'm sounding
kind of ugly this isn't the season for
healing but he's got work to do
yeah right there will be a time to be
devastated can't breathe lost everything
whole world shattered totally get that
but right now he's got a job to do and
that's to care for his dying wife
to make sure that all the nuts and bolts
are are and and teaser crossed and eyes
are dotted he's got to do that man
he can't just say like nope not talking
about I can't talk about I can't talk
about it you can't do that and if he if
he just can't physically then he needs
to go talk to somebody ASAP so he can
get some skills real quick
because he I promise you after she's
gone and he looks back and says I just
netflixed and numbed out the last three
years of her life dude that will haunt
him for eternity
he's got to plug in
but sometimes in his defense sometimes
people don't know what plug-in means and
that's where you might be a gift to him
to be able to say this weekend I'm
coming over we're talking about a will
we're talking about the funeral we're
talking about the wedding
do what you got to do but we're having
that conversation
and give him some guided Direction on
here's the things that have to happen
but I love the idea of you sitting with
your sister and saying we talk about it
almost everything
and from this point forward we're going
to talk about everything
yeah
well she's actually the one
the one I've tried to talk to my husband
about it and
he he just he saw him so she's like and
I told her I said well I you were always
there for me I will be here for you
through anything beautiful
now what she's done is she's been very
vulnerable and she said
um
are you still going to love me even
though it's about to get real real hard
and you say yes
and both of you all have a different
picture of what that looks like
and so I want you all to clarify
together over the next two or three or
five or however many months what that
looks like
okay okay
what is your expectations about her
funeral what is her expectations about
um Extended Care what's her expectations
about skilled nursing or going to a home
what are her expectations all the way
through
okay okay
and I'm telling you the more you can
interject silliness or an old story or
just no words at all and just grab her
hand
these These are the moments of life
it does the soil doesn't get richer than
this even though it's so painful and so
hard
yeah
and I need you to I need you to hear me
say
most of my career has been spent sitting
with people who reached out and said I
need you and the person said no thank
you or didn't respond
and so the fact that you said I'm in
it's my turn now
I want to tell you man they don't make
sisters like that everywhere I'm really
grateful for you
thank you
that's awesome
let me give you uh two other quick
pieces of just wisdom I've picked up
over the years running my mouth thanks
to people who are either passing or who
are hurting
thing number one is silence is always
better than stupid sayings that are in
pillows
okay
the second thing is almost without fail
people who have cancer people who are
dying people have terminal illnesses get
put in a position to make sure everybody
else in their world is okay and that is
not their job
oh okay so her job isn't to make you
feel better her job isn't to take care
of her husband her job is to stay as
healthy and well as she can for as long
as she got as long as she's got
and so when she says no no I'll just
I'll just you smile and go nope nope
yeah
right and she's your sister you can put
it across the room and say if you can go
over there and get it then uh then I'll
sign it all right you can do that
you can have all kinds I mean you can
you can have and she'll she would smile
yeah and say I get to take care of you
now
it's my job
God she's so lucky to have you
I'm blessed to have her through my whole
life she's always been the one to take
care of me a big sister is kind of like
a second mother
for For Better or Worse right yeah
exactly yeah
well do this for me
um
periodically give us an update would you
on how she's doing
okay
um I'd love to see you standing in as uh
at that first dance in your wedding if
you have a picture of that at your
nephew's wedding
okay I would love to see that that'd be
awesome and um
just be fully present in the upcoming
season as hard as it is
I will
be fully present
because these are gonna be
um
the years you look back for the rest of
your life and said I was fully in
it won't stop the hurt the hurt's gonna
be there either way
but you'll be able to sleep knowing I
was there I was fully there
you're a blessing blessing blessing
Christina thank you so much for your
call